ah
[Música]
en europa polonia es conocida por ser un
país altamente restrictivo en las
condiciones del aborto legal y seguro
pero la situación se volvió más difícil
durante la última semana cuando
estallaron protestas multitudinarias
contra un fallo de la corte
constitucional que el pasado 22 de
octubre dictaminó la posibilidad de
interrupción del embarazo solamente en
casos de violación de incesto y cuando
la vida de la madre esté en riesgo este
cambio ha sido indignante para las
activistas feministas porque
anteriormente también se hacía una
excepción en caso de anomalías fetales
que se consideraran graves sin embargo
el más alto tribunal decidió que esta
última variable era incompatible con la
constitución lo cierto es que la ira de
los manifestantes es aún mayor porque
esta decisión aunque no era inesperada
si se dio en pandemia cuando
precisamente el gobierno prohíbe las
concentraciones y las manifestaciones y
siendo la crisis de coronavirus un
periodo de especial vulnerabilidad para
las mujeres como lo han denunciado
durante todo este año insistentemente
los grupos de derechos humanos
[Música]
en irlanda el aborto ya es legal y desde
2019 las clínicas de maternidad pueden
realizarlo de manera segura en las
primeras 12 semanas de gestación después
de este periodo sólo pueden realizarlo
si corre peligro la vida de la madre o
si el embarazo es totalmente inviable
sin embargo la ley por sí sola no ha
podido erradicar las creencias
religiosas en un país tradicionalmente
católico y a menudo las mujeres se
encuentran con obstáculos por ejemplo
tienen que investigar quiénes son los
doctores que se han registrado de manera
voluntaria para realizar este
procedimiento y los grupos antiaborto
frecuentemente se instalan en las
afueras de las clínicas de maternidad
para tratar de disuadir a las mujeres
para que no se realicen esta práctica
así que a pesar de que la ley fue votada
contundentemente en 2018 continúa el
estigma en la población irlandesa
[Música]
la defensora de los derechos del niño en
rusia ha propuesto reducir los fondos
para las clínicas abortivas en el país
según su propuesta la cantidad de dinero
asignado a las clínicas que practican
abortos debería ser inversamente
proporcional al número de interrupciones
voluntarias del embarazo que practican
puesto que según su manera de pensar
cada clínica debería estar interesada en
salvar a cuantos más niños mejor desde
1920 rusia es el primer país del mundo
en legalizar el aborto como opción para
la mujer aunque durante la época de
stalin se prohibió la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo la tasa de
aborto siempre ha sido muy alta en rusia
el acceso a la información y a los
métodos anticonceptivos tras la caída de
la unión soviética han ido rebajando
poco a poco las cifras de abortos hasta
unos niveles más normales
hoy en día en rusia el aborto es legal
durante las primeras 12 semanas por
cualquier razón pero algunas entidades
como human righs watch denuncian que
últimamente en muchos hospitales de
moscú están rechazando practicar abortos
para centrarse en las víctimas del
coronavirus
[Música]